Former Republican Congressman
Adam Kinzinger,
who is now a senior
CNN political commentator.
Good morning, sir.
So we've got a lot to talk to yo
This morning.
I think listen,
we'll get to Santos in all of th
You heard our conversation
with the former attorney general
Do you think that the the public
do you think they see the distin
between the Trump documents
and the Biden documents,
or is it all one thing to them?
And what do you make of the disc
He says as a human being,
it may put, you know,
the attorney general
may think differently
about whether he would prosecute
But as the attorney general he's
got to do his job.
Yeah, I think I mean,
I think what he says is accurate
So, first off,
if your
you know, the good thing is law
does nuance right?
The law does differences.
The law can look at kind of diff
and what was intention.
And that matters.
Politics doesn't do that very we
Politics
everything kind of blends togeth
And what we wanted
in the last few years is
if you can just throw
enough doubt on the wall,
that's enough to kind of win you
So I think from a human perspect
I think,
you know,
for Attorney General Garland, he
going to continue to prosecute
even the Joe Biden case,
if necessary, correctly
Politically,
this is very dispassionately,
the second batch. I mean, goodne
Very damaging for the current pr
And does
a lot to throw
a lot of cloudiness into the who
narrative here that's going on.
Yeah.
The White House will still
be facing questions on that toda
But when it comes to
what's happening on Capitol Hill
and in some of these Republicans
who were initially
not voting for Kevin McCarthy,
then they voted for Kevin McCart
Then we saw them
get pivotal, critical seats
on big committees yesterday.
What is your reaction to people
where it seems like
they are getting seats
on these committees
in exchange for their votes for
him as House speaker?
So I'd like to pull the curtain
a little bit.
And you know, Caitlin,
I know you've been following
Congress for a long time
and you remember some of these d
for the last 12 years since I've
which is every time we get to so
that is going to be tough to pas
but has to pass or a speaker ele
What ends up happening
is this group called the Freedom
I call them the Freedom Club.
They wait to hold out and they k
and actually
they're quite effective at it.
They know that
leadership means their votes
and they'll extract anything
and I knew after the first ballo
that Kevin McCarthy would be spe
because he would give up anythin
to become speaker.
They were very smart
in terms of the politics of this
to hold out
and extract things that the Free
never would have gotten otherwis
They never would have gotten
what we called a committee assig
Now, here's the problem.
The so-called moderates,
I'll just call them
kind of the regular Republicans,
the Tuesday group, Republicans.
They have as much or more power
than the Freedom Club does.
The difference is,
because I was part of this group
we don't like to blow the place
We generally
are the ones that want to work
as a team and get along.
And so we are always outmatched
because when it comes
to things like taking hostages,
the one that's the most
powerful is the one, pardon
the pun, that's willing
to shoot the hostage
and that's the freedom kids righ
And so they were able to extract
out of Kevin McCarthy.
And unless
and until the so-called moderate
come forward
and do things like vote
against the rules,
which they didn't do, easiest vo
they're going to continue
to get run over.
I'm not sure if you've heard of
this guy named Jorge Santos.
We got a hold of his of his resu
And I mean, honestly,
if you look at his resume,
I mean, Caitlin,
I really sure that's his name. Y
Yeah, exactly.
But I mean, we're
we're not you're not being facet
What do we know?
But do we know if anything on
his resume is true?
You called for him to
to to resign, right?
And he came after you on Twitter
basically saying
if we have the tweet,
I think he said, like, you know,
go on CNN or something
and whine about it.
There there it is right there.
Cry about it.
We go cry on CNN.
Yeah. What do you think of of th
Well, look,
here's the other thing
about throwing a bunch of
confusion on the wall.
I think I heard
Kevin McCarthy
say, well,
a lot of
politicians or somebody said
you know, they exaggerate their
Holy cow. Okay, let's be clear.
This is not exaggerating a resum
It's a total fabrication.
It's one thing if somebody you k
you see this, a lot of military
they say, you know,
they had a certain job and they
I think that's disqualifying any
But people have survived that.
It is another thing
to have obviously questionable
where your money came from.
But secondarily,
say you were Jewish
and then say, no, I was Jew ish.
Okay, come on.
And then your mom died in nine 1
Then she did
everything about this guy is a l
That is a fraudulent presentatio
So if I'm running a campaign ad
and I lie, I openly lie on it.
If I say, you know, the sky is g
they can come
after me
and have that pull off the air
for being false.
If I don't know that
this guy lied about everything
to 700,000 people,
I don't think he can continue.
And I don't see how Kevin, I get
His majority is tight.
The people decide the battle.
Kinzinger doesn't get to decide.
You know,
the Republicans in Washington
don't get to decide.
The Democrats don't get to decid
The new York state.
Republicans don't get to decide.
The people get to decide.
That's basically what his that's
what he's saying
and that's what McCarthy is sayi
And the thing is
that people didn't decide
because they thought he was some
totally, totally different.
It was a way and a fraudulent el
He has to resign.
I think he does end up resigning
because I think the pressure is
going to be too great.
Well, you know, we'll see if he
Okay.